[Music]
yeah
it's been 14 years since we first got to
know Ashley Simpson on her MTV reality
show I can't wait to see what happens
next
fast forward to today she's a mom and a
wife and returning to TV with a brand
new docu-series on e alongside her hubby
and then ross fans will get a peek into
their lives as the couple records a duet
album there's a lot of questions you
know and and we wanted to give some
answers but we also more wanted to just
show who we were so and show our love
for me like it's been ten years since
I've you know put myself out there just
been being a mom and loving every bit of
it was just sharing with the world a
little bit of us and our family and our
music while some couples avoid mixing
business with pleasure the Rosses say
their marriage is rock solid in no way
do I think that if a relationship was
meant to be together no marriage is
meant to be together that anything like
a show or being in this industry can
change that it is new and it is you know
definitely something new for us and but
something fun and you know we've had a
good time doing it yeah I think there's
always nerves and different things
excitement stuff like that but I don't
think any fears come from our
relationship which is anything yeah we
love each other love yeah we good well
your kids be on the show yeah yeah yeah
kind of keep them away cuz yeah go with
them every day so they will be but we're
strategic and how we do that yeah could
we see you know your mom or Tracy on the
show or is Jeff you're gonna make it if
there's gonna support people that you'll
see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]